see how cold this is that's how you know
you don't have a property you're not an
alcoholic it's because you think you
care about the temperature and the taste
I feel like every other alcoholic just
drinks to consume large amounts and I
don't care what the [ __ ] it is or what
it tastes like yeah and I know some
alcoholics I'm not gonna name anybody
and run even allude to anybody but
there's some dangers out there that you
know there are some couple of guys out
there that have to stop but it's so hard
to have what do you say I wish you know
I
there was a I'll tell you from my
perspective I have talked I haven't
really talked about this totally but I
think everyone knows it but like I did
Rogen's podcast and we were talking
about how much we drank and they were
asking me Ari and Tom and Joe were
asking me and they asked me how much I
drank on a daily basis and at the time
it was a high number and I I remember
not wanting to say the real number I
don't know how to represent myself in
that way like only because I've just
been honest yeah I know they're my
friends and I know that they care about
me and I know that and I know that
people listen I know that that's the
thing about podcasting is you want
honesty that Chuck Chuck story is like
like that's like tetanus tea you know
like yeah and I told them in its second
I told them I was like I regret this
immediately and then yeah woke up the
next morning going like I [ __ ] up my
career like no one will ever be able to
come watch me cuz I'll think that it's
sad that I drank and no no and and then
we did that sober October Bert thing and
it was awesome was really great and it
kind of read
structured the way I drank a little bit
yeah and I'm gonna saw my nights where I
go off the [ __ ] rails but for the
most part I remember I remember saying
out loud to people because I was
drinking a ridiculous amount at the time
but not bad not like violent not angry
just drinking and going to sleep I
remember saying to people going if you
have a friend who do you think drinks
too much make it into a challenge that
changes their lives like you say we're
all not gonna drink for October or we're
all not gonna drink for November we're
all gonna do it no
find your weaknesses we're not gonna do
it and make it fun and don't make it
blame me and don't make it like
accusatory like an intervention make it
enjoyable because those three guys
literally probably changed my life for
the better in that I didn't drink all of
October I didn't like yoga and I know I
did hot yoga 15 times but I feel like a
real alcoholic though wouldn't be able
to do it I agree I agree because the
people that are in that challenge right
who was in that challenge me Tom Orie
and Joe Tom who Segura okay Ari Shaffir
yep Joe Rogan yeah correct yeah none of
you guys are drug addicts oh yeah but
Joe is smoking weed
I know but he is not one nobody I know
but even I think not to speak for Joe we
do that but Joe said that it was really
interesting to not smoke weed for a
month because what happens is you get
into a you get into a rhythm in life for
month for me my rhythm was I have a hard
time going to sleep so for me a couple
drinks puts me to sleep
I don't sleep great but that whole month
taught me that I can totally go to sleep
without drinking I do not need to drink
to go to sleep I'm a grown-up
I can definitely not gonna have
nightmares I'm not gonna be I don't need
a half a xanax
I can totally sleep without drinking so
for a whole month I didn't drink
I didn't iPad by barely drank coffee
I barely drank coffee like it was really
enjoyable I didn't lose any weight like
it wasn't like a game-changer but I
think that's the approach if you have a
friend who drinks too much and you're
worried about him try the angle of like
hey we're all in this together let's
make this a month-long challenge because
for me and I was definitely drinking a
lot way too much then I enjoyed that
month a lot and I I it crept over into
February to March yeah March practically
yeah like where I just went I'm home I'm
not drinking like I'm gonna be home I
want to be at the girls I want to just
be home and I didn't drink for four
weeks and all of March and so I don't
know that's the way I look at it when I
think people look at too much of a
pointy finger thing but right but that
solidarity I think it's the proper kind
of support it was I was legit support
like it was legit fun support like I'd
run into those guys at the store and
they
like you're good yeah it was fun we go
to hot yoga together the four of us and
we just bust balls and laugh
hysterically and then you go home and
you wouldn't want to drink you would
never want to go get drunk after you
just hang out with your friends for two
hours so I don't know I don't know
anything about recovery or anything so
that's my two cents well you don't need
to know and I'm gonna say this about you
also as well if math I'm a that I
believe that human beings there are
twenty prototypes males twenty with
their female twenty female prototypes
twenty males
basically what I'm saying is is that is
that if we were Androids if we were
let's say we were Android company we
made Androids right like a working class
and remodel we have twenty models I like
this now you can manipulate get to each
model right the way you want you want
one model a little fatter a little
shorter yeah but generally the type I
feel like you and I are the same model I
grew that thank you dude can I tell you
when I agree with that the most yeah
when the I hope you're cool talking
about this but when the Chronos would
see it video came out oh my next day you
gave the talk holding a cigarette oh my
god I was like I'm that guy see this I'm
in I've never identified the thing you
did the way you talked about it the way
you expressed regret and it was such in
the vein that I live my life where I
went I went oh my god dude Ike I can I
tell you I've pictured where you were in
life meaning like location I was like oh
he's in Los Feliz he's on he's not by
his back step right by that door like I
visualized oh my god I'm so glad you
brought that up yeah because that video
plagued me for real yeah because this is
how that happened so I joke that montage
video of Mencia stealing and whatnot and
I will vision I visualized I visualize
how it happened to you can I can I tell
you what I thought happened baaa I'm
gonna tell ya I thought you walked up to
the store
what's going on yeah someone's like pop
you have a cigarette yeah I'm Moe - and
you lit a cigarette and someone's like
and then then everyone starts walking
out and you're sitting there by the wall
and they're like Bobby what do you think
about a Carlos mysterion you and you
just jokingly went you mean Ned not
knowing what it yeah yeah and then and
then just walked away and then all
sudden the video comes out and Carlos
called you and was like bro what the
[ __ ] oh yeah very severe E similar to
that I envisioned that so much yes I
were a little bit of the you were a
little bit of the nail in the coffin in
the storytelling you yeah we're a little
bit of like the that this is so we tell
me how it really this is have what
happened okay so I'm at the Comedy Store
and Brian Redman at the time wasn't
reddit Brian Redman up today Brian
Redman was Joe Rogan's guy his video
article for his podcast guy everything
and Brian read Brandon would always have
a camera just on right and so I'm
walking at night like I always do and
somebody asked me and what about Mencia
stealing I don't see the camera was this
the same night that this whole thing
went down or no they it was it was a it
was a collage of a bunch of different
shows a different night right so he go
and I said I didn't know there was a
camera there any and they said but Ben C
is stealing the guy steals and whatever
you know then I noticed the thing and
then I go to Brian I go don't put that
out there and Brian goes no I mean Joe
makes the final decision but we're
probably not extend they it is right so
here's the [ __ ] part by the way you got
to give a shout-out to Brian Redman for
shooting contest a week earlier than
shooting this and then realizing I got
Bobby Lee saying that he steals that's a
good producers mind like really crafty
that's the best Brian red bands a ganks
he should I wish he just started a
production company where he made vlogs
for comics he's so good in so many many
are like
great at comedy but as his artistic arm
is really in in branding in like yeah
making content he's so he could've had
an empire though I mean cleared out at
me started about that so I would have
been like writings comedy I think you're
right you got what you guys are doing
with us also were involved in that you
guys are creating a company that can
last and that can eventually produce
things and get into the mainstream and
we need we need one of us to I wanna I
don't want to lose train of this story
yeah we need one of us who's big to
decide not to go on Netflix and release
their special on all things comedies
platform and that will not happen I
won't do it I definitely won't do it
yeah I'm not the one I'm already all of
you guys did it you bill burr re you
know Tom maybe yeah I've never done a
special I would do it on that how come
you aren't doing special I just
yeah so that video comes out now I can
do one or two things called Mencia and
apologize profusely or avoid them right
and I couldn't do the second option
because MADtv was attached to the mind
of Mencia we shared the same studio
really on Hollywood Center studios so
you you know stage whatever aren't
connected right so I'm sitting in my
dressing room and I get a knock on the
door oh wait you shot that at Hollywood
Center studios it was my first TV show
shot there yeah of course you do you now
you can sit the steps and that yeah yeah
and then it wasn't Ned it was his
cousins and his brothers hey bro
the videos our bro oh yeah yeah I didn't
do it coward right
right like in that way well you got a do
a rebuttal bro yeah I don't want oh yeah
you have to do Ned wants it so Carlos
called
ever they put me on those stairs did you
call him when you talked to him did you
call him Carlos for net and like net in
life and all I got always yeah yeah he
started I he discovered me really yeah
Mencia was that without Mencia I would
have an agent or anything I opened for
him for seven years
I so funny I just met him Rhys Iraqis
memorial oh wow we had through cow head
we had talked me and Cal was like oh he
might come to the show and I was like
how cool I don't have any problem with
him yeah I never I mean I've never had
any beef with him I mean I obviously I
know the backstory of him but like I
don't I don't I've never experienced
that story but my experiences with Ned
were of a boss employee and when I was
in 1997 when I didn't have a car because
bro come over to my house I have a
present for you he bought me a car I
mean that's the kind of relationship I
had was it took you home with him to
Honduras yeah it took me to Honduras to
visit his where his homeland is and his
family yeah and I lived in a village for
a month so I might ties with him were
really deep Wow so when that video came
out it was hurtful to me because I feel
like I betrayed a friend but what was
that what what I said was that true yes
yeah so now I'm caught in thing oh dude
so they're exactly I mean you're
explaining me and Jamie yeah that's me
and Jay yeah so then he goes come on
through a video and I was like I have to
so that's why when you see it I'm like
you know was pensive and whatnot but
when that came out if you read the
comments when they came out or song uh
it was brutal yeah I know it yeah
you don't you don't think I came out
[ __ ] like you're done in comedy you rat
you piece of [ __ ] I mean it went
I mean not just five or ten I'm talking
thousands there's a weird thing but in
between having a loyalty for somebody
and then having loyalty to yourself like
like what I like my words what I say is
true
versus like a live for this person right
and it died [ __ ] me up bad with j bx i
was like i was like i wanted i was i was
taught i was i'm by the way I was taught
to protect him like I was made sure like
working for somebody when you're their
employee and that's it's very clear what
that is
yeah there's no like for all use that
don't understand like there are guys
like like and I'll say Joe is like re
was always his friend and and worked
with him tom was his friend and worked
with him Joe was his friend worked with
him if you work with Joe Tony if you
work with Joey work with Joe yeah you
got to eat like I will say this I very
candidly Jay made it very clear to me
one time that I worked for him that I
was in his employee mm-hmm and then then
there becomes this like weird [ __ ]
loyalty where you're like I don't want
to [ __ ] up the boss's job because that's
my job like it's not like it's where
your body's because it's also we weren't
buddies we were posting show business is
intertwined in it so you're dealing with
now dreams are in the fabric of the
relationship what's good for the
company's cook for me yes and so and and
then you you do get lost in that the one
I gotta tell you about me give us what
you're saying I don't want to know what
it was really clearly about it I don't I
have no problem sharing everything okay
so when I watched your video with the
Carlos thing I then I identify with you
because Jay was telling a story that
happened to me you know about this right
now Tracy Morgan story no it's a great
story
tell me cuz I'm not gonna tell you the
story but
hey you tell the story that happened to
me and he was taking it as if it
happened to himself and so I I found out
about this he told her on Opie and
Anthony he told it for the first time on
Opie and Anthony was the first time I
heard him say this happened to me it
killed me it really killed me by the way
I don't mean anything negative about J
I'm just telling you stuff that happened
J's come very far away in his life from
this moment I'm talking about right now
and I'm a very far away away from this
I'm not slandering J I hope I hope you
don't see this I'm just telling you to
Tories of two guys who were friends and
worked with each other yeah just like
you and Carla yes so it's just sharing
and so well the first time I heard it it
broke my heart
that's it didn't it didn't I wasn't
angry I wasn't mad I didn't feel
betrayed it broke my heart I was like oh
why would he do that that way yeah and
then and then and then it it got bigger
it got much bigger and it's kind of
spiraled out and then I talked about it
on Rogen's podcast very candidly like
we're talking right now
yeah well you don't realize people are
listening yeah I talked about Rogen's
podcast and the same thing that happened
to you with Carlos happened to me but
directly with Jay of like don't like why
would you do that like it was really
like bizarre [ __ ] reality yeah and I
think Jay would admit this there was a
bizarre reality where like he was
panicky he was losing his mind I was I
was doing what you did we just were like
I'm being honest yeah I don't know
another way to be right now I've been
honest and you I can't say anything more
of Jays intent after that he stopped
being friends Wow
and but at the same time that
boss-employee friendship is just
unhealthy yeah it's almost the reason I
never brought anyone on the road with me
cuz I was like I don't want that [ __ ]
yeah won't you never feel like I'm your
paycheck I've had managers say to me hey
man my kids got to eat you gotta don't
don't do that and I'm like what and I
fire him immediately I can't have that
like I want whatever I do on stage to be
what I do on stage but man when that
stuff of me and Jay happened I look back
to that video you shot and the comments
later
I'm being dead serious probably and I
hope this doesn't sound bad
took years it took literally years I
read how you smoked a cigarette I can't
believe it alright I remember that when
you brought it up like 20 minutes ago it
brought me back to it like it just like
it rattled me in the [ __ ] car because
I'm I knew by the way I apologize to
both Jay and Carlos for this episode
that's the time I don't I don't mean any
hate on either of them yes a grown man I
realized that my words may affect the
way people code and see their ticket
sales I don't want that for them I I
hope that you just enjoy laughter and
you go and if that's your thing enjoy
their [ __ ] blah but but I remember I
remember watching you visibly shake with
a cigarette and going like he doesn't
mean this he this is this is that
Stockholm Syndrome yeah this is a
hostage sand they treat me good mom
remember that's so vivid yeah and I was
I was I'll just say you know you know in
a form of representation I was asked to
do what you did yeah and I chose against
it because of your video not because of
not anything other than I was like I
don't I know Bobby doesn't want to do
this like I [ __ ] remember that so
vividly but I would have never done it
if they weren't at my doorstep
they were like six guys bigger Hispanic
guys visibly kind of aggressively angry
like they felt betrayal because I'm like
it's very Shakespearean I stabbed you
know my master behind the back oh by the
way let's let so let's let's let's
Ballpark this from the other side yeah
understandable to an extent because yeah
I remember I got an etheric right after
the JME [ __ ] went down I biggest mistake
I ever did was telling Joey Diaz I was
in therapy and he was like dog [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you meet me every morning for 8:00
a.m. coffee and me and Joey had a damn
coffee for a month long one month every
day and he go taught us everything you
need to [ __ ] say
and I would dump on him dump on him and
then Joe come back and be like here's
the
problem [ __ ] but but uh but I I I
know that feeling
I know that [ __ ] yeah feeling of like
going did i betray my master yes
did I was being real I was being honest
and I was being real
[Music]